foreign
this is your Tech news briefing for
Thursday March 2nd I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Salesforce is facing the same problem a
lot of tech companies are after a period
of massive growth it's now got to deal
with an economic downturn during the
boom times the software giant spent
money putting the company's name on
skyscrapers in San Francisco New York
London and Tokyo it increased its
Staffing numbers by roughly 60 percent
in 2020 and people familiar with the
arrangement say it agreed to pay actor
Matthew McConaughey more than 10 million
dollars a year to be a creative advisor
and TV pitch man
now things have changed the company laid
off 8 000 workers in January and
remaining staff say the family culture
that Salesforce has prided itself on is
taking a hit
wsj Tech reporter Tom Dutton wrote about
this along with tech reporter Catherine
binley Tom is with us to discuss what's
happening at Salesforce hi Tom thanks
for joining me thanks for having me so
Tom tell us a little bit about the
culture at Salesforce what has it been
like historically the company really
built its culture around this idea of
ohana which is a Hawaiian word meaning
family or familial bonds and the tenets
of ohana as far as salesforce's CEO Mark
benioff defines it is there is a
connection among all employees employees
to their customers and even to the
broader Community around them and so at
this kind of Oneness and string that
connects all people that are attached to
its products the company and then the
places where they live and that it sort
of pervaded this whole idea of how to
build Salesforce and that took also the
form of other kind of perks and wellness
ideas like meditation and yoga tell us
more about that I mean the wellness day
is the sort of investing in the
individual employees like what was it
like to work there well the wellness
days was a thing that was introduced
earlier in the pandemic which basically
gave people a day off during the month
to kind of put their mental beings back
together and that was something that
continued for months during the pandemic
until finally it was rolled back uh at
the beginning of this year and then the
meditation you know on every floor of
Salesforce Tower and there are
Salesforce Towers all over the world
they have a meditation room uh which I
visited actually last week and it's what
it sounds like it's a room on a floor
that has places for you to sit and I
guess Center yourself mentally
like other
come to make Cuts because of the current
economic climate so how is it doing that
what is it losing there's a lot of stuff
that's changing at the company both just
in how it runs its business its General
operations but also on the wellness
front
specifically to the wellness stuff they
have rolled back the well-being days
they had during the pandemic
signed a booking arrangement with
Trailblazer Ranch it was called which is
a kind of wilderness Retreat near Santa
Cruz that employees could have come to
and both been trained to learn how to do
their jobs better but also do things
like yoga and hiking and that
Arrangement is now gone partly because
there wasn't as much attendance to it
but also this is a company that's having
to keep a lid on costs and things like
that are just no longer really an option
if you want to talk about the broader
cuts and where the business is going
right now they laid off 8 000 people at
the beginning of the year and that was a
response to slowing growth and just a
challenging economic environment and
this new emphasis by investors that
Salesforce really do a better job
keeping its lit on costs and keeping it
more in line with its Revenue growth
which is slowed down yeah let's talk a
little bit about Investors how are they
kind of approaching Salesforce and its
position at the moment well I mean it's
been pretty aggressive its stock is down
47 from its peak in 2021 and so there's
been a disenchantment with tech overall
in the last couple of years but specific
to Salesforce their stock is down much
more than like the NASDAQ index and you
know more dramatically over the course
of the last few months activist
investors have been piling into
Salesforce to try and push for change do
we know more about
typically what kinds of changes those
activist investors are asking for the
most specific changes that we know about
from an activist is from starboard value
which in a presentation last year said
pretty directly that they believe
Salesforce is not really meeting its
potential when it comes to the amount
that it's spending so given its revenue
and the amount that it's growing they
should just be far more profitable and
this isn't specific to starboard but
just generally looking at the market the
adjusted operating margins for
Salesforce which is looking at their
profit margins taking out certain
expenses like stock based comp those are
substantially below some of their direct
competitors like servicenow and Adobe
and so if you're an investor and you see
a company like Salesforce that for years
has had lower margins than its
competitors and salesforce's argument
has always been well we're growing
faster than them so we need to spend
more to grow more now that they're not
growing as much that argument looks a
lot weaker how all of these chain
sters the cuts that Salesforce has
already made
morale of the employees who are still
there I think it's a big question I mean
you've seen the stuff that's been rolled
back and that has made a lot of them
upset I mean we reported in the story
that there is this slack Channel called
airing of grievances which has 22 000
members and people are sounding off
they're talking about their frustration
at seeing things roll back and there's
just general overall fear that the more
that activists push for Change and push
for a rolling back of expenditures the
kind of things that made Salesforce
unique are going to go away as well how
has Salesforce and Mark benioff
responded to the shift in morale he
still believes strongly in Ohana as the
connecting Force inside the company and
to its customers when I talked to him he
didn't say Ohana is we're done with that
stuff now it's all about efficiency he
really thinks it can evolve to be
something that fits within a more
productivity oriented company rather
than just a growth oriented company so
he recognizes that times have changed
and
the business is Paramount is a thing he
told me directly in our interview so and
then from screenshots of their internal
slack conversations that I got to see
he's really mixing it up with employees
that are complaining so if someone is
saying they're unhappy with some of the
draft policy proposals he's going
directly into slack and giving his
opinion and pushing back on things and
trying to give the perspective of the
CEO which look I mean it's 160 billion
dollar company it's not that common to
see a CEO dealing directly with their
employees in a you know communicative
platform all right that's our reporter
Tom Dutton thanks for joining us Tom of
course thanks for having me and that's
it for today's Tech news briefing if you
want more Tech stories check out our
website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]
foreign